au début du compliment ils se sont
rendus compte qu'ils avaient une hausse
des tchats parce que tout se passe par
quatre quand vous connecter bien
arrêtons les violences points ou via le
site du service public vous tombez si
vous enlevez rentrer un code postal en
zone de police sur la plateforme donc
c'est une plateforme nationale parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
une hausse des violences qui était
comment je pourrais dire en train de se
passer est aussi on a eu l'impression en
fin d'après mes collègues qui sont là
contente parce que moi je suis juste en
renfort qui a une hausse des chais pas
le confinement a permis aux gens
peut-être de réfléchir sur eux mêmes et
se sont rendus compte parce qu'il est
beaucoup de campagnes aussi que ce
qu'ils avaient vécu il ya un an il ya
deux ans il ya quelques années et paix
était une infraction et venez nous en
parler nous demander ce qu'ils pouvaient
faire à ce moment là
[Musique]
alors y est le dispositif avec les
pharmacies où la victime pouvait se
déplacer dans une pharmacie
il ya eu le dispositif du 114 qui permet
aux victimes d'envoyer un sms si elle
n'ose pas parler si l'agresseur est
juste à côté
c'est du coup c'est assez compliqué de
passer un coup de fil
et puis à prévoir nous au niveau de la
plate forme je vous dire que les
signalements sont fait comme d'habitude
c'est à dire que on envoie signalement
s'il est une attraction évidemment et si
la victime le désire on envoie une
affaire un signalement pardon au
commissariat territorialement compétent
qui va reprendre contact avec la victime
qui sera déjà ce qui s'est passé parce
qu'il est non il y aura une copie
l'enquêteur aura une copie du chat et du
cou la victime va venir au commissariat
en étant en ayant rendez vous ce qui lui
évitera de re expliqué à l'accueil de
son histoire
[Musique]
la première chose c'est si vous êtes
témoin surtout n'hésitez jamais à après
le 17 on a eu beaucoup de gens qui se
connectaient qui nous disait j'entends
en ce moment des violences sur mon
voisin mais je n'ose pas appeler le 17
j'ose pas donc s'il fait l'eau surtout
n'hésitez pas et n'attendez pas parce
que des fois voilà le fait d'attendre
c'est un peu trop tard donc voilà ça
c'est là une des premières leçons il
faut pas hésiter à appeler le 17
parce que si on ne passe pas loin de la
plateforme nous on va après après nos
collègues du commissariat compétent mais
on perd du temps et malheureusement des
fois on sait que des victimes dans
quatre tentes devant elle donc ça c'est
la première chose si vous ne savez pas
si vous êtes témoin lui qui vous ne
savez pas si ce que vous avez vécu ouzou
est une infraction de pas n'hésitez pas
à vous contacter à vous connecter pardon
à la plateforme
nous on pourra même des mots et même
peut-être des qualifications pénales
devant ce que vous ce que vous vivez et
si ce n'est pas une infraction parce que
des fois ça peut arriver ou si vous le
désirez si la victime ne désire pas
déposé plainte
on oriente vers les associations